nos dicen que el cuadrilátero abc de es
un cuadrado por lo que todos sus lados
son iguales y todos sus ángulos internos
serán de 90 grados también sabemos que
el segmento f que es perpendicular y
corta por la mitad
el segmento bc también nos dicen que el
arco ac es parte de la circunferencia
con centro en b es decir este es el
punto central de la circunferencia y
esta es parte de esta circunferencia
asociada con toda esa información nos
piden encontrar la medida del ángulo de
d que es formado por esteve
y d nos piden encontrar este ángulo los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo ustedes mismos y después
continúen bien el vídeo en donde les
daré algunas pistas sobre cómo
resolverlo la primera pista es que
traten de dividir este ángulo en
triángulos cuyos ángulos sean más
sencillos de encontrar dado nuestros
conocimientos sobre triángulos
esto procederé a resolver el problema
ustedes pueden pausar el vídeo en el
momento en el que ustedes consideren que
están listos para terminar de resolverlo
por su cuenta el punto aquí es darse
cuenta que esto de aquí en b es el radio
de un círculo por lo que en el centro a
la circunferencia cualquier punto va a
medir lo mismo por lo que la distancia
debe aa es la misma que la distancia
debe a e y es la misma que debe hacer lo
importante aquí es saber dibujar las
líneas correctas para visualizar los
triángulos correctos voy a dibujar una
línea que quizás los oriente sobre cómo
generar los triángulos necesarios voy a
tomar este punto y voy a unirlo con el
punto
aquí está ahora esto se pone interesante
porque cuál es la relación entre los
triángulos
s bueno ambos comparten un lado el
segmento eje y bg es igual al segmento
que se tiene la misma distancia estos
en la misma distancia pues están
dividiendo este segmento la mitad
el segmento veces y ambos tienen un
ángulo de 90 grados
así que por ángulo lado ángulo estos dos
triángulos serán congruentes los
triángulos o el triángulo
d
es congruente con el triángulo
c g
por lado ángulo la por la congruencia
lado ángulo lado y esto nos dice que los
respectivos lados y ángulos de ambos
triángulos serán iguales así que por
esto nosotros ingerimos
el lado que se va a ser igual o va a
tener la misma distancia que el lado b
es decir este lado
tiene la misma longitud que este lado de
acá y sabemos que este es el radio del
círculo por lo que ese también va a ser
igual al radio y ya habíamos dicho que
veces es la misma distancia del radio
también así que esto también va a ser
igual a el segmento b c y aquí me estoy
dando cuenta que me faltó indicar que
este segmento de aquí es el que está en
común por estos dos triángulos
que había mencionado anteriormente pero
bueno regresando a nuestro enunciado
actual encontramos que este es un
triángulo equilátero por lo tanto va a
tener todos sus lados y sus ángulos
internos iguales cada uno de sus ángulos
internos será de 60 grados
60 grados
a 60 grados este de aquí
+ 60 grados nos va a dar 180 grados que
es lo que debe de medir el total de
grados de los ángulos internación
triángulo entonces escribimos nuestro
triángulo b
sé
es equilátero
equilátero
platero
por lo tanto la medida del ángulo b es
que es parte del ángulo que estamos
buscando de ese este aparte de ángulo de
todo el que queremos encontrar esta
medida es igual a 60 grados
ya tenemos resuelto es una parte del
problema solo nos falta encontrar el
ángulo de ese esta parte de acá como
podemos encontrar este ángulo
sabemos que el segmento s es igual al
radio del círculo y este lado de aquí
abajo el de cee ya que tenemos un
cuadrado pues también medirá un radio
los cuatro lados medirán un radio lo
mismo estos lados van a medir lo mismo
estos van a medir lo mismo estos porque
son cuadrados
ok lo escribimos
de vido
a que es un cuadrado
el lado cede
es igual al lado de ce que también va a
ser igual al lado y se lo importante es
que se den cuenta de que los dados s i d
c son los mismos son iguales por lo que
eso nos indica que este triángulo que
estoy señalando aquí es un triángulo
isósceles y sabemos que en este tipo de
triángulos los dos lados iguales o
piernas son congruentes al igual que los
ángulos de la base si encontramos el
ángulo del vértice c este ángulo de acá
el ángulo de c
estamos a 180 grados y el resultado lo
dividimos entre 2 para encontrar los
ángulos que nos faltan aquí en la base
de este triángulo equilátero vemos que
tenemos cada ángulo de 60 grados del
cuadrado sabemos que este ángulo d
d
es de 90 grados este es un ángulo recto
tenemos estos 60 grados estos 90 grados
restamos 60 a 90 y este ángulo de acá
nos va a quedar igual a 30 grados en
nuestro ángulo acá así que para saber
los ángulos de este triángulo isósceles
si nosotros llamamos a este ángulo
x y a este otro ángulo de acá también x
porque son lo mismo y decimos x
x
30 que es este ángulo deberá ser igual a
180 grados
y aquí vamos a ir
simplificando esto 2 x + 30 debe ser
igual a 180
2x
si restamos ambos lados en la ecuación
30 180 menos 30 nos va a quedar 150 por
lo que el ángulo x va a ser igual a 150
entre 275 grados todos estos son grados
así que estos segundos van a medir 75
grados este ángulo que nos faltaba de
acá es de 75 grados por lo que la medida
del ángulo
d es la suma oa ser igual a la suma de
60 grados
75 grados
iguala
135 grados y con esto hemos terminado